[Music]
and that's not right news left submitted
by geo is fine Wow Wow
[Music]
a tennis coach busted for child abuse
wants to use the Stand Your Ground law
to defend hitting a five-year-old Oh a
hundred percent a tennis coach yeah
what Stand Your Ground law hahaha it's
like a castle law for your body that's
like if somebody is threatening you you
can put them down like literally you can
shoot them as well yeah for real yeah
it's like a Florida law I think that's
tight no yes Laura I think we have to
defend ourselves from these
five-year-old terrorists and we have to
stand our ground and say no no more
five-year-olds Tyler year-olds are the
biggest [ __ ] time to kick them like
a [ __ ] I want to know the context
because I've heard of a five-year-old
killing their family how do you know
I've heard that I'm not sure it feels
five but just like his parents took away
his xbox and he blasts his parents in
the head in their sleep see Wow I don't
know if it was five and all killers home
was five years old so young yeah it's an
important point nobody makes yeah that
Hitler was once five years old yeah
that's right people forgot supposed to
be able to make that point though I bet
he is cute
good point all right so the tennis
instructor his name is oz mayor Torres
he's from Miami and so he's being
charged with third-degree child abuse
from a degree how many degrees what's
first-degree tell me yeah how do those
going degrees maybe it's like murder
like first-degree murder or is it like
martial arts where a third degree is
hella gay oh yeah
or is it like if I use a if I like use a
weapon that second degree and if I like
throw a bike at and that's third degree
oh I've had third degree then for sure
there
someone throw by Katie my dad through a
office Jeremy uh well deserved
yes I got a full office you're like one
of these guys with the wheels on it yeah
oh my god how old were you I was uh I
had to be eight Dan you probably look
you were 16 I was pretty other side so
what you through it I caught it like
this not bad yeah so he's being charged
with third degree child abuse because of
an incident that happened back in August
2016 so police are saying that he took a
boy's child sized racquet and struck him
with it while he was out a playground at
a church there is surveillance video I'm
gonna show that to you guys right now
that's [ __ ] up man would it be killed
was it his own kid though
because that makes it a little bit
better no Oh dad was this like in 1992 I
know it's really bad quality oh this is
interesting fact up a random kid so I'm
gonna start and not move for a second so
you don't be right here oh it happens
really quickly I saw that so it'll
repeat once more on the hip no looks
like the arm not the arm yes it was um
the victim he ended up having like
injuries to his right arm and his
eyebrow weight right arm and eyebrows
with the racket yeah like like the
rackets big I guess Oh ba-bow and so
they're saying that so his lawyers are
trying to say that he before that
happened the child had him at gunpoint
no well I kind of sounds like that so
before he hit him with a racket the
coach approached the kid coach
approached the coach approached the kid
who was with other kids and the coaches
saying that he had to separate the child
from the other children because
apparently the child wanted to injure
the other students so at that moment is
when he grabbed the racket and as he was
coming down he like accidentally hit him
hit the victim so that's what that's
[ __ ] that's accidental that kids
back was turned to the coach and walking
away from him so it was in the motion so
he takes the record comes back down to
grab him and so oh I can see how he's
saying is that I wanted I want to
believe
I want to believe fake so you grabbed it
and he's trying to go oh well you don't
see you there's a there was a B you're
trying to swap the B oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah right yeah it's trying to give
her in the bug bite grabbing it through
the kid who's trying to walk away he's
grabbing the kids in my sight stand your
ground I know that's the weird part I
guess that's my question
no his lawyers are saying that he
defended himself and others from this
preterist kid the lawyer says in this
case mr. Torres defended himself and
others during and immediately after the
commission of several violent acts
perpetuated by the alleged victim oh my
god mr. Torres responded and naturally
proportionately and in defense of
himself and others to the action Peck
rated by the alleged victim I agree
that's what the motion is leading
because now there the motion is citing
Florida's passage of The Stand Your
Ground Hog Day
can we read the statute please thinking
let's hear it stand your ground
yeah it's sometimes called line in the
sand or no duty to retreat law is is a
justification in a criminal case whereby
defendants can stand their ground and
use force without retreating in order to
protect and defend themselves or others
against threats or perceived threat let
me read the law for a law where men can
be [ __ ] men yeah it's about time the
funny thing is it's a five-year-old
karate a five-year-old yeah it's tough
you don't need to defend yourself why
does he go why don't you just say like
yo dude I was trying to I was trying to
just stop him from hitting the thing and
I literally do this to a five-year-old
while he's swinging and he'll never
touch you you can just push him on the
ground okay like just so Lily just go
like that and they're on the ground like
if he's really gonna hit someone you
guys ever pushed a little kid before
it's hilarious thing they go right down
they they [ __ ] fall
extra fast you don't even gotta touch
them you could like go yeah
what's wrong like stable structure so
they just [ __ ] love playing with kids
man [ __ ] because you're athletic you
superior to the two only them exactly I
love that you like bullying small people
it's [ __ ] to me that's great look at
this guy yes the perm you got a smile
during your mug shot you really do I
love hats
wait is that a mug shot no that doesn't
look like a much disease is this gotta
be a mug shot but from our angle looks
like he buzzed the middle no I think he
just taking a picture in front of a gray
wall no reason why did his hair look
like he's from the 60s
no his hair looks like he's got like a
Washington power wig but it's black yeah
like it's pretty weird looking at his
mugshot looks like a head shot
he's a black Quaker do it so yeah
they're trying to say that it was
self-defense
and also that the injury was
unintentional and it occurred by
accident you don't say self-defense I
guess my only problem with it I wouldn't
said self-defense
our bar was the best one like Allison I
was hitting a B yeah you can't see the
[ __ ] be in the veil right I was trying
to swat a bee away it was about the Pope
the kid was like you can't see it but
I'm actually in the middle of a match
and I hit the ball I'm sorry the way not
a [ __ ] winner or something you say
something yeah I don't know you got a
try but seeing it's self-defense I don't
I don't know who's the lawyer that came
up with this there's a lot of kids I
would like to punch in the face though
how many kids do you know guys the
church select you know those [ __ ]
kids you want to punch church kids
eveness yeah Church kids are the worst
yeah you could think of hide under the
guise of Jesus right you can't even
[ __ ] strike them if you want to
because it's like well God what it want
think we topic he'll tell the people an
austere judgmental to those little kids
you know what's worse is the parents who
don't know their kids very well and they
come up and they're like well how was
Little Jimmy hey do you think he's gonna
go to a Ivy League college like let me
tell you something let's see if he
passes [ __ ] first grade all right the
little dumb [ __ ] yeah those questions no
they asked these because they asked us
like what are their behaviors like are
they very smart are they
smarter than the other kids in class
it's like no they're [ __ ] dumbest [ __ ]
your kids a [ __ ] demon dude what the
hell were the parents that are in denial
well you want to level with them like a
man your kids not doing well it's like
he's a troublemaker whatever and then
though like argue like a [ __ ]
what the teacher yeah like I asked your
kid what he wants to be when he grows if
he says can opener I can't help you I
want to see a David so parent-teacher
conference [ __ ] I asked you kid to make
a clay pot he [ __ ] you couldn't even
do that you think you can [ __ ] jack
off all day she stood in the corners
[ __ ] kid dude
oh you can't be a teacher the circle the
circle he tries to put in the square
look a little [ __ ] palming in the
corner she does my taxes and she's
[ __ ] six come on
well if you guys were the parent of this
child what would you think would you
think it was like oh it's an accident I
could see if my kid was an ass a hundred
percent thank you sir no I'm not
pressing charges yeah Thunder kid
you know in my neighborhood my mom would
give other kids spanking sometimes when
I was growing up and that was normal
like other parents would regulate other
parents kids all the time just keep all
of us in check and they'll be like thank
you right exactly they weren't like yo
what did you why'd you hit my kid it's
like no I like you thank you like I'm
sorry he was such a little [ __ ] yeah
yeah but now it's like do what you do my
kid man oh yeah you can't touch my kid I
touched my kid pal okay I'll see you in
court [ __ ] like it's like everyone's
got lawyers now and she never get
defended by my parents man I would get
like in fights at school and the kid I
get my ass beat right I come home think
I'm asking my past oh [ __ ] I got no
friends at this place yeah is it with my
homies yeah my parents wouldn't leave a
word I said
you have maybe a fun time I was at a
Toys R Us and there was just like 40
year old dude who was birddog of my
little brother who was like [ __ ] what
doggin like he's like he's like staring
at him like a lot like a lot and then it
had a [ __ ] anyway or aggressively in a
horny way I was I was like I was like
nine years old right and my little
brother was like three and he's walking
around and this dude I see him and he's
wearing sweat pants and he's got a
[ __ ] boner in his well yes and he's
like reaching into his pocket and I
didn't know what the [ __ ] he was even
doing what
wasn't right yeah I'm just like this is
weird I don't like this guy stopped it
like it was right and I told my dad that
and he's like you're [ __ ] lying you
know about the pedophile instead my
dad's like you're a [ __ ] liar don't
even say anything the whole ride home ya
know but wo you are such a troll though
you probably did that a million nine was
that oh at nine I don't know are you
probably probably your dad's gonna
respond to you that way I'm pretty damn
sure you [ __ ] with them so hard like
getting no [ __ ] sympathy from us I
know damn right I [ __ ] [ __ ] stain on
your face you like yeah nice try Gullu
takes you there like puts it down below
[Laughter]
[Music]